okay so this was submitted by
conlan postema on instagram well a bunch
of people sent this in wanting you guys
to react to
lori harvey and michael b jordan being
official what do you mean two beautiful
people going at it
and that's how they made it official
that weird pick i bet they get married
like a drink i hope so dark uh demoting
she's so fine
i bet they're getting married well don't
say that
and did was there a caption or it was
just like no it's no casual i don't see
anything
no captioning that's just gonna make it
official apparently they saw each
other's family
and everything did she make it official
let me see yes yep she also made it
together oh and that's how people know
that this is real because michael b
jordan posted her michael b jordan
doesn't usually poke she doesn't post
shoes she doesn't neither one of them
future but besides future no one really
but all her story though not on her not
on her post though on a story she's a
playboy
yeah she never made a post no i didn't
know what she was the one where she's uh
in the uh
come on you know one you know exactly no
no that's not doing what he's talking
about
how do you hear them this is the
original moment when they started
yelling chin
this was
yep michael b jordan listen when you're
when your mic will be joined that's
that's what that's
that's the get that's the lane you're in
man i mean that's the lane you're in
if they made it that official they're
getting married no i ain't no i've seen
this all the time
she's she's been with a you know few
minutes she has the catalogue she's not
done mike you'll be joining like the
other [ __ ] that's what i'm saying he's
not like he's a he's the real he's like
a dudes dude
like he's a good like family guy yeah
he's a childhood yeah but we all know
that
dude she's been when he's the only one
that's been in gta can we all can we all
look
no no no he hasn't been in g i mean
he has been a genius he's like a normal
dude though those other guys yeah
[ __ ] boy listen thomas no reason why
she's dating him because he's the
currently reigning
sexiest man alive and they haven't seen
me with a haircut yet too
you're telling me you can [ __ ] with
michael b listen you're a good looking
dude i appreciate that
you're great yeah you're a chrysler 300.
he's a royals royce i have you ever seen
a 300 next to a royals royce
you think they look similar you go and
then they pull up you're like
god he said you were chrysler 300. well
hold on
and cr and creed you the new corvette
those are great mid
engine way to go chevy have you ever
seen it next to a real
ferrari 488 with a copied off of
you that fry 48 pull up you look it
that's you
you could get there well here's the
thing yeah what are you gonna get to
that a little bit of work of course
yeah you're totally good a lot of people
in crete you saying they were saying
side by side you don't think he could
get there get where
where put us side by side
in the world
michael b jordan and malik b all right
now go to my let's go
like go to like uh hold on go to my best
pitcher what's your best picture all
right i know yeah
you're right i'm gonna say i'm sitting
down
the one by the tree the one by the tree
yeah go go to the one by the tree
this one no no no oh that's the [ __ ]
that's that's right that is about you go
all the way down go all the way down go
all the way down
go all the way down and it's coming up
right
that's a good one no no no no no no no
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on
hold
on hold
on
hold
on
no no no go now go down i want i want i
want there let's go
yeah that's a fair one okay it's a
pharaoh that's a fair one that's a fair
that's a good looking
look at this look at this [ __ ] here look
at you hit me like my grandfather with
facial hair he looks like [ __ ] okay
thank you look at this
look at this look at it go ahead and
zoom in and out go ahead
pick your best picture we got to pick
his best dude hey michael b
jordan you keep saying and then he gets
out his bank statement
and then he's like come to the crib well
i got
xbox i mean all right well i tried to
defend you malik
oh [ __ ] you're right i just dawned on me
yeah i tried
okay all right malcolm michael b jordan
as killmonger
i'm gaining weight though i'm in the gym
again you're a good looking dude
he's the best looking dude well he
listen he had work done
let's be honest let's call it work done
bro his teeth done
and then come on bro we know he's on
steroids right there yeah come on come
on
exactly so let's that's not even fair
like i grew up with before
that's steroids huh oh yeah that's good
yeah for creed
oh really oh come on bro chappelle but
anyways
anyways listen we all can agree that
nice guys finish last right i think
she'll be
a nice guy he's a nice guy but she's
she's [ __ ] with all these [ __ ] boys
she found this really that's why she's
posting it because she found a real one
and you know he's directing the next
creep i know holla at me bro
you might nope not anymore wait hold on
you out well hold on we don't know that
now
he's directing and he's probably he's
directing it yeah yeah oh [ __ ] bring
back my character please
that's dope i need it bring back your
character remake
no i love you man but never mind all
right sorry i tried to defend you dawg
i appreciate you i rode with you god
bless you yeah what else you got
okay how about that when i get off stage
at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song